can I join the prime minister in his
words about the first minister of Wales
and the sad loss of his wife everybody I
think knows just how close they were and
I know that he's absolutely devastated
by her loss at the weekend
Mr Speaker when the Prime Minister
briefly emerged from his hibernation at
the weekend he raised more questions
than answers so in the interests of
integrity and accountability can he set
the record straight did his now form a
chair tell government officials that it
was under investigation by the tax man
before or after the Prime Minister
appointed him prime minister Mr Speaker
I appointed the independent advisor to
investigate this matter fully
he he has set out his findings in detail
over the weekend and on receipt of those
findings I took action and I'd refer The
Honorable gentleman to the independent
advisors report
[Music]
[Applause]
oh come on anyone picking up a anyone
picking up a newspaper in July last year
would have known for hmrc and the
National Crime agency were investigating
months before he appointed him Mr
Speaker the independent 6th of July new
chances finances secretly investigated
by the National Crime agency the
observer three days later 9th of July
revealed officials raised flag over tax
Affairs before he was appointed
Chancellor the financial times the next
day 10th of July pressure bills to
explain his finances is he saying his
officials hid this information from him
or was he just too incurious to ask any
questions
Mr Speaker as I've said before at the
dispatch box the usual appointments
process was followed with respect to the
minister without portfolio
no raise with me at the time of his
appointment but as the independent
advisor to report makes clear there was
a serious breach of the ministerial code
and that's why I took decisive action on
receipt of that report
[Applause]
so in relation to his former chair his
defenses nobody told me I didn't know I
didn't ask any questions
is the prime minister now also going to
claim that he was the order premises Mr
gullis we heard enough last week I can't
hear what you're saying I might not be
able
to say but I could certainly see you
both moving it'll be moving outside if
it continues prime minister
so for his former chair nobody told me I
didn't know I didn't ask any questions
is the prime minister now also going to
claim that he's the only person
completely unaware of serious
allegations of bullying against the
Deputy Prime Minister before he
appointed him
prime minister Mr Speaker Mr Speaker the
The Honorable gentleman asks ask these
questions about what was known and I
followed due process I pointed
independent advisor as soon as I was
made aware of uh as soon as I was made
aware of new information the independent
advisors conducted this process but if
he is so concerned about what people are
saying and they're so concerned about
behavior in public life then recently
one of his own MPS was forced to speak
out because being in his party had
reminded her of being in an abusive
relationship
and then and then and then his own
office was caught undermining her
I'll be trusted to stand up for the
women in his party he can't be trusted
to stand up for Britain
but the last count the Deputy Prime
Minister was facing 24 separate
allegations of bullying according to
recent reports some of the complainants
were physically sick one says they were
left suicidal
how would he feel if one of his friends
or relatives was being forced to work
for a bully simply because the man at
the top was too weak to do anything
about it
Mr Speaker I I noticed he didn't say
anything about why one of his own MPS
describes being in his own party
and Miss Nipper when I was made aware of
formal complaints I instructed a leading
independent KC to conduct an
investigation because I take action when
these things happen but what did he say
at the weekend he said at the weekend
that hate had been allowed to spread
unchallenged in the labor party under
his predecessor he was speaking as if he
wasn't even there but he was sitting
right next to him supporting him for
four long years not challenging and it
is typical of him Mr Speaker declining
to lead sitting on the fence carping
from the sidelines
and and never standing up for a
principle that matters
I want to hear both sides and I'm not
going to have be interrupted by either
side and I'm particularly looking for
people who want to continue this because
we will sort it out today
speaker it's just like one of his
predecessors who treated questions about
conduct it's something to brush off who
thought that ducking responsibility was
a perfectly reasonable response for a
pirates at least In fairness his
Precision didn't go around pretending it
was a paragon of integrity and
accountability
but on that subject was it a coincidence
that the two people who arranged an 800
000 pound line of credit for the former
prime minister were both shortlisted for
Plum jobs at the BBC and the British
Council
[Music]
yeah I mean it's rigorous it's
transparent it's set out in a public
code of conduct and indeed and indeed
was fully supported not just by an
expert panel members but also by the
cross party dcms select committee
including including where labor members
describe the appointment as impressive
but Mr Speaker Mr Speaker back back back
this week in terms of what is actually
happening to the people of this country
he voted he voted this week with the
unions to oppose minimum safety levels
he voted with just stop oil to water
down the public order Bill and what do
the unions and just stop all have in
common they bankroll him and his party
Mr Speaker
so while he sides with extremist
protesters and union bosses we stand up
for hard-working britons and school
children
yeah
after 13 years in power trying to blame
the labor party for his failure to sort
out the strikes is it's rank pathetic
the Tory passes addiction to sleaze and
Scandal has done huge damage to this
country and the cost to the public keeps
adding up we've got a justice system
letting murderers walk the streets heart
attack victims working hours for an
ambulance an economy that's shrinking
quicker than his leadership
and even I couldn't quite believe it
when I saw that his government is
expecting taxpayers to pay the legal
fees for the member for Uxbridge
defending himself over his lockdown rule
breaking a quarter of a million pounds
surely even this prime minister can put
his foot down stand up to his old boss
and tell him he made the mess he can
pick up the bill
Mr Speaker he can't stand up to his
union bosses he can't he he can't he
can't stand up for Britain's school
children today
stand up for the women in his party Mr
Speaker
we're getting on we're halving inflation
we're growing the economy we're reducing
debt we're cutting waiting lists and
we're stopping the boat while he can't
even figure out what he believes in
we'll keep delivering for Britain